[Musique]
les français pour leurs vacances rêve
souvent de dépaysement d'îles lointaines
laissant leurs ennuis à des milliers de
kilomètres à calais dans le département
du pas de calais de nombreux habitants
n'ont pas du tout ce même souci pour eux
le dépaysement c'est dans la tête et pas
besoin de faire des heures de voiture ou
d'avion amour patrick bource toute
l'année patrick et maryse ont rêvé de ce
moment les valises sont bouclées les
enfants au prix d'un maillot de bain
direction les vacances les stress des
grands départs me semble la plus nerveux
vivement qu'on n'arrivera pas parce que
bon bah c'est le grand père on respire
on pense à rien là bas c'est à deux
kilomètres seulement de chez eux
la famille a dit à calais chaque année
elle passe ses vacances au camping de
calais et elle n'est pas la seule
on est à peu près une dizaine dans le
coin qui sont ou se caler la ici
derrière pareil il y en a sur le côté et
pour tous et des vacances parce que bon
danseur de la maison on n'est pas
stressés on est en plein air on est tous
réunis bon piont trade et des
attractions contretemps shelly tous
ensemble pour l'aveyron la pétanque la
belote
même si la vue est limitée d'un côté des
immeubles de l'autre le pauvre c'est
leur petit paradis pour rien au monde il
ne partirait ailleurs on a les occasions
de rentrer chez nous pour que la femme
puisse laver son linge quoi que ce soit
et en même temps bon bah on n'a pas
toujours le climat mais on est bien
comme ça a toujours été comme ça en
famille je crois qu'on aurait du mal à
partir
[Musique]
tu n'as pas envie d'être dans un camping
par exemple sur la côte d'azur
oui ça sera bien
voisin de palier collègues de travail
côté de vingt ans presque une photo de
famille
les calaisiens sont si nombreux qu'ils
sont devenus indispensables à la vie du
camping où est ce que vous pensez à
leurs vacances année prochaine
bon on est sûr de revenir sur calais
loeb ont l'excusé parce que c'est
l'heure de la pétanque
merci et au revoir
[Musique]